[Music]
hey everybody welcome to every damn day
and yes we know it's a Friday but we are
on every day on Twitter on our show
extra damn day so don't leave a comment
we know what day it is anyway today
we're gonna be talking about Comedy
Central's corporate and we're gonna hope
that our boss is not watching what she
isn't and basically I think we're
probably all pretty terrible employees
just on hold but we're great comedians
okay and I have been loving company
central corporate season two is now it's
on at I haven't written down Tuesdays at
9:30 I watch it online I love that you
were ready to be like okay and they'll
probably be like shouldn't you've known
the time yes
but thank you for watching anyway the
first clip that I want to show what
struck me so funny because like I am
absolutely one of these guys and so here
we go
[Music]
Matt looking dapper today okay okay
you look tired Oh sucks to be a woman
doesn't it yeah do you wanna speak for
the women on the couch yeah you know
there's a lot of work that goes into it
and a lot of times it doesn't pay off
you're not really respected as a person
is that I don't respect you and whoa but
we don't deserve respect
yeah I respect you
shall we pivot oh yeah I will I will say
mine is closer to hers than his I get up
I work out ya know I don't even know if
working out works to be honest with me
cuz I just continue to eat I do
zero self care at all and it's
frustrating like you have the body I
want
I'm very Midwestern style let's get up a
shower yeah I drink my coffee I look at
the news and then I pack my bag and I
and I pat the dog on the head and then I
give her a little kiss and slip some
time and then I leave the house I think
you don't want us making fun of your
world are we make it too easy she's so
good what are you gonna do and you're
it's crazy your routine it's like you
don't even have kids but you're already
a grandpa yeah absolutely is impressive
yeah what are you like drinkable a broth
or morning routinely at 4:30 for about a
month Natasha would drink a bowl of
broth 4:30 p.m.
yeah well also 4:30 a.m. you just work
with every 4:30 the other people get
together
III do something similar to what you do
I don't shower never do that ok
and but I do I need to sit quietly with
a cup of coffee before I have turned on
my brain like I can't I just sit on the
couch both of my dogs flanking me on
either side that says don't even talk to
me before I had my coffee I got at
Michaels Arts & Crafts
yeah but the part of the end where Adam
lustick ass and do that get like yeah or
not asked or but he tells you like well
you feel it I guess that's a question
yeah like you are tired yeah it's like
so
biting does not YouTube more than
anybody no one actually like I'm gonna
I'm invisible here I could steal
anything I want from this office yeah
which brings me to the next clip about
an annoying co-worker Jon you wanted to
see me yes Kate I spent the whole
morning putting together something
you're going to want to see these are my
wife's
7 brothers Randal Robert Roger Ronald
Richard I'm enraged
technically they're illiterate and
they're all single if you can believe it
now Randall is a little off but once you
get to know them it's actually really
funny like a deer that thinks it's a cat
Jon why have you done this well if
someone trying to send me up one time
guys anyone at all no you have not yeah
I gave you my friend Matt's number he
texted true is so hot ok and you didn't
do anything about it
I gave you my friend URIs number but he
was not single at the moment and I also
gave you my friend URIs number and he
was also not saying you're hearing
sounded great my area was very fun
perfect response yeah I don't know any
single people already URIs ok I had a I
had a co-worker who I hated and everyone
hated which was good to like have
because we all can hate her together
yeah but one time I was getting free
snacks in the snack area and I put my
hand in to get some snacks and she said
oh you're one of those and I was like
what is this gonna be
wait is this me no it's not you boy yeah
you had wait what did you do I put my
hand in like the in like the cheez-its
bag to get cheese's uh-huh and she was
like oh you got a warrant I gotta pour
it out
you forgot water to your palm in the
cheezer's I know your hands were
touching them you're all over the place
your hands are on the keyboard and then
you go in there and you palm the the
communal cheese no I think it's good for
everyone's microbiome that I did that
see this is so much I'm so weird about
Jordan is that he will do that but then
you also I know you have like a no shoes
in the house rule yes there's other
things where it's like you're very clean
and proper and then in like you know
when it's other people you're just like
when appropriate but like there are
times when we should increase the
diversity of our microbiome I am what
are you just gonna sneeze on the snacks
like it's a good thing I'm gonna sneeze
on you and you're gonna say thank you I
to take my shoes off when I get in the
house I instantly wash my hands I've
outside clothes and inside Chloe too yet
I let my dog lick me deep in the mouth
that's true and I see him lick his
butthole
like I'm like I'll give you 30 minutes
yeah the germs are cute Fair Play Gideon
stuff this is when I worked at a gym if
this is a story about me I'm gonna flip
out you've never been to a gym
I bet I could do more pull-ups than
anybody here except for Jordan okay so
you can't women to women competition
which I would still be you in but I
accept you also have no body weight
anyway I randomly a floating head yeah
you just float off into space this this
is not don't do that there's a whole
other website for people to look at
like that
yeah and I'm on that too check it out
she was very annoying and had like she
was just very annoying but she always
made baked goods always and brought them
in and they were gym yeah I know but I
never lost me when I worked there but
they were so goddamn delicious I was
like in the end everyone wants sweets
yeah nobody really wants to work out
they just want to feel good so there you
have it if you suck you should like
learn a skill so people can
put up with you and you can get away
with being who you are yeah here's our
next clip which is kind of like that
cookie sure thank you no thank you
as an accountant it's my job to keep the
lid on the cookie jar which brings us to
the expense report from your recent
business trip to Los Angeles what I need
for you to answer me is yes
how did for Hampton de Ville employees
in the course of one dinner at Marcos
sombreros Mexican bar and grill managed
to drink 16 margaritas that's really
messed up yeah okay we're definitely
spend more and we have but I think that
our company culture likes it when we
drink a lot
I mean it is true like they are always
greasing up the tubes
I never what are you what are you trying
to convince are you drunk right now
glasses there's like fun pushing off I
only read and they yeah I'm like what is
this persona really we drink at work
last Thursday yeah every Friday when we
do our script read I do not recall maybe
because you're black oh there you go
this brings us to a great point friends
as adults hard to do right and so
usually just become friends with people
that you work with because when you're
not asleep you're at work and then you
die at some point yes so here's this
clip from corporate
it's crazy that Hampton Deville makes a
SmartWatch almost identical to the one
in society tomorrow nomads organized
religion is crazy the resurgence of
neo-nazism is crazy my mom is crazy but
the fact that Hampton of ill made an
evil SmartWatch and you bought it not
crazy the guard wrist is evil HD
strappin is awesome it acts as my
personal assistant monitors my blood
pressure involuntarily but I know it's
for my own good it also records how many
steps I take see before I didn't know
how many steps I took but now I do so
that's good
Wow yes steps that sounds incredible and
it has all my key card info on it so I
can beep right through at work in two
seconds yeah it definitely seems much
easier than just doing this I totally
see why you'd be willing to share all of
your personal information for such a
time-saving convenience are you watching
society tomorrow yes I was up all last
night binge watching it I love it it's
the only good thing in my life my son is
kind of not talking to me right now
real taco I feel like Joshua's
reflection in the mirror is like a
metaphor yes just wait till you get to
Episode four it turns out oh no spoilers
oh I'm sorry I think the show is no to a
genre nice music leg swag like you've
made a new friend so sweet
it's like TV's TV and like the
technology and stuff it's like the only
thing you know pop culture stuff it's
like why do people talk around the water
cooler it's cuz like we have to talk
about something yeah like oh what'd you
do this weekend yeah where'd you get
that limp am I have you seen friends
yeah what if you're into like such
strange stuff that when people ask you
innocuous questions then you get written
up by HR yeah very stuff all weekend
which is now illegal in Germany
illegal in Germany I mean it's a gateway
to animal so I get it for sure
bestiality is oh yeah maybe everyone
import is related so yeah Ryan eats his
dog no but like if you look at the
clip it's all like brother and sister
don't do brother and sister activities
though he does I heard this except it
yeah I'm ignoring this it's not
accepting it's ignoring what I've made
one friend it made any friends we're
friends huh yeah yes I mean you guys
hang out what are you doing I've hung
out with all of you outside of work
really true what have we done maybe one
day with the rock concert will we bomb
for a half hour
oh that was fun yeah yeah that was fun I
like that how about that Brian show only
one who makes an effort it's just he's
not our friend
corporate Tuesdays at 10:30 9:30 central
and follow them on social at corporate
on Twitter Instagram and Facebook this
has been every damn day
[Music]